Hollywood is an ever-changing landscape
and nobody knows that better than action
stars at years gone by from world karate
champions that kung-fu prodigies these
actors were born to be action heroes but
for one reason or another they all wore
out their welcome in the movie business
Brian Bosworth was playing the villain
long before he got to Hollywood a
college football all-american at the
University of Oklahoma the Boz was the
best young linebacker in the country in
the mid 80s but he was also the most
controversial I enjoy dishing out pain
and I enjoyed getting pain I thrive off
of that the NCAA banned Bosworth from
competing in the 1987 Orange Bowl after
he tested positive for steroids in
protest he attended a nationally
televised game wearing a t-shirt with a
slogan that insulted the NCAA despite
these antics Bosworth was picked up by
the Seattle Seahawks and went on to play
three seasons in the NFL before a
shoulder injury forced him to change
careers before long Hollywood cast him
as an Alabama cop at war with a biker
gang in 1991 stone-cold though critics
thought he was upstaged by Lance
Hendrickson Bosworth went on to appear
in a string of supporting tough-guy
roles as the 90s decade faded taking his
career with it he found Jesus later in
life and still pops up in the occasional
faith-based movie little-known character
actor Fred Ward was poised to become
Hollywood's next big action hero at one
point a former boxer and military man
Ward's manly resume and chiseled
features made him an ideal fit for the
genre after the Air Force in various
Italian movies Ward's first american
film of note was 1979 s Escape from
Alcatraz in which he played one of the
convicts trying to break out of the
notorious island prison his performance
made an impression earning him the lead
in 1982 s time writer the adventure of
Lyle Swann Ward plays a dirt bike racer
who accidentally travels back in time to
the Wild West where a band of outlaws
tried to steal his motorcycle the movie
was so bad that some critics walked out
but Ward would be given one more shot at
stardom unfortunately for him 1985 s
Remo Williams the adventure begins are
in fact less than half its budget as the
title suggests the film was intended to
launch a franchise Orion Pictures
reportedly wanted to create an American
James Bond but Remo Williams this
reception didn't spawn any sequels
Ward's brief stint as a leading man was
over
you believe with a good guys
when Hong Kong film producers traveled
to the States in search of the next
Bruce Lee in 1983 nobody expected them
to recruit a female martial artist the
Hong Kong film industry was dominated by
men back then but that had never stopped
Cynthia Rothrock before Rothrock was a
karate champion who defended her title
against male competitors in an era when
there wasn't a dedicated woman's League
film producers recognized her cinematic
potential and signed her up to a three
movie deal Rothrock proved extremely
popular with moviegoers in Hong Kong
where she became known as the blonde
fury she ended up making a total of ten
movies overseas before returning to
America to launch an assault on
Hollywood sadly it didn't pan out the
Spyders success overseas Rothrock
usually played second fiddle to male
American stars she half expected to get
a call when the Expendables brought
together a bunch of action stars from
years gone by but the phone never rang
French actor Olivier Gruner began his
martial arts training at age 11 after
being bullied at school the Paris native
joined the military after graduating
joining an elite unit comparable to
America's Navy SEALs when his military
career ended he got into prizefighting
then worked the odd security job one
such role would change his life forever
in 1987 Gruner landed a security gig at
can in a savvy act of self-promotion the
kickboxer decided to put up posters of
himself around the film festival one
producer took the bait and decided to
cast him in a role originally meant for
jean-claude van Damme
his first fell 1990s angel town exceeded
expectations and 1992's nemesis
performed even better
unfortunately follow-up roles didn't
materialize quickly there was a
three-year delay before 1995 s automatic
Gruner continued to feature in
low-budget action flicks in the years
that followed but when it comes to
Hollywood stardom Gruner had missed its
chance in the early 90s Canadian actor
and martial artist Jeff Wincott set out
to be Hollywood's biggest action star he
had fronted 11 straight-to-video action
flicks by that point though they hadn't
been widely seen in America nevertheless
the action genre was booming at the time
and Wincott was the full package a
proven actor and a genuine Taekwondo
champion Wincott always considered
himself an actor first and a fighters
second Hollywood didn't
the Toronto native made a ton of
low-to-mid budget action movies in the
90s but when the decade came to an end
casting directors quickly lost interest
in later years Wincott stayed on the
scene with roles and numerous TV shows
including 24 The Wire and Sons of
Anarchy but his feature roles were all
but gone
he still stars in short movies but to
say they get produced on a shoestring
budget would be a massive understatement
2016's behind bars cost they reported
$33 to make you know I remember my first
protein bar I'm an actor and I was doing
dramatic roles Texan actor David Bradley
replaced Michael Dudikoff in the
American Ninja series when the latter
tried and failed to move on to bigger
things Bradley a former car salesman
skilled in various martial arts
traditions made his debut in 1989 super
low-budget American Ninja 3 blood hunt
Bradley starred in the next two American
ninja movies before taking on the role
of Jack Ryan no not that Jack Ryan
in 1993 cyborg Cop and it's 1994 sequel
despite modest expectations Oh Bradley
failed to capture public interest and
fell off the radar after the release of
1997 s crisis his final film rumor has
it he's teaching martial arts classes in
Texas but as far as the industry is
concerned David Bradley is vanished
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]